I'm Jeffrey hasbun I'm a physicist let's
answer some questions off the internet
this is physics
[Music]
support at Pizazz 91 asks how do black
holes influence the SpaceTime around
them anything that's massive will bend
SpaceTime so if I think about this sheet
of elastic as being SpaceTime with
nothing in it as soon as I put something
that has any mass in there it bends
SpaceTime around it if I then take
something really small like this marble
and give it a little bit of umph it'll
orbit around that object and it's that
following curved SpaceTime is why the
Earth moves around the Sun so if I have
a really big object and I look at what
that looks like in SpaceTime that bends
it even more the key with a black hole
is making something that's really really
dense and as I increase that density
that stretches the SpaceTime further and
further and further down so much that
light can't escape that curvature
anymore and that's what we call a black
hole at pedals for Jack asks wait what's
SpaceTime SpaceTime is the thing that we
live in it is four dimensions three
dimensions of space and adding to that
the dimension of time it's what we're
moving through as we sit still it's what
we're moving through as we walk through
our house Afeni smack asks how do you
split an atom what you're really doing
is you're splitting the nucleus and
let's say this is the nucleus of a
uranium atom and what you do do is you
shoot another particle at it usually a
neutron really really fast and when you
shoot it at the nucleus the nucleus
breaks into
pieces into a few different pieces that
are smaller nuclei and when you do that
it also as you can see releases a lot of
energy and that's where the first
nuclear bombs came from and that's where
the energy we get from nuclear power
comes from user aier 8203 asks if the
sun just suddenly disappeared it would
take us 8 minutes to find out but does
Earth still orbit where the sun was or
will it go out of the orbit immediately
after it disappeared the answer is it's
going to keep moving around the Sun for
another 8 minutes we don't know here on
Earth that the sun disappeared because
it takes 8 minutes for the light to get
to us from the Sun it also takes 8
minutes for any changes in gravity to
get from the Sun to us at Mike biani
asks hasn't read a godamn thing about
physics since high school hey did you
hear about the gravitational wave I have
heard about the gravitational waves and
I helped publish some of the recent
results about gravitational waves in
case you haven't been paying attention
gravitational waves are these expansions
and contractions of SpaceTime that are
traveling through SpaceTime at us from
super massive black holes at the centers
of far away galaxies one of the really
neat things about gravitational waves is
they pass unimpeded through the universe
we can actually get closer to the Big
Bang using observations of GRA
gravitational waves so they're going to
teach us all kinds of neat stuff about
the early Universe at only 166 asks one
question how do you detect gravitational
waves in SpaceTime the first way we
detected gravitational waves a few years
ago was using lasers in big vacuum tubes
and you split a laser you shoot it down
two tubes and you keep track of how far
apart the mirrors are using the lasers
to tell you the distance between the
mirrors that's called ligo the second
way that we've learned to detect
gravitational waves is by using these
exotic Stars called pulsars they are
really fast spinning stars that pulse
every time they come into our line of
sight we watch those pulses over time if
the pulses arrive a little bit later or
a little bit earlier we can attribute
that to the expansion and contraction of
SpaceTime between us and those Stars I'm
part of a collaboration that looks at
almost 70 of these stars in all
different directions and we've been
monitoring it for almost 20 years at
thek hatib asks I'm genuinely paying you
$1,000 if you answer this right is light
a wave or a particle the answer is that
light is both a wave and a particle
we've known the wav like properties of
light for a long time there's a classic
experiment called the Young's double
slit experiment let's show it to you
right now let's take down the
lights we're going to take a laser
pointer here which is not how the
original experiment was done I'm just
going to take this plate that has a
little tiny slit in it and point the
laser through it and what happens is it
splits the light into two different
waves and those waves are a little
separated from each other they're not
quite matched up because two different
waves are meeting up with each other and
this is what we call interfering and
that's what gives us that pattern
there's actually two waves hitting there
and they're constructively interfering
so the black spots are actually the same
as what what you get in noise cancelling
headphones one of the waves is
cancelling out the other wave and only a
wave behaves like this lights please
light is actually something bigger than
a wave or a particle it's something we
call a Quantum field and that Quantum
field has particle like characteristics
and wav like characteristics and we can
measure both so I think you owe me a
th000 bucks dude at Dr zgc Disney asks
what's the difference between fision and
fusion anyway do you want to go fision
with me I don't want to be anywhere near
where fision is happening fision is
where you take a nucleus that's really
big of an atom and you break it into
pieces Fusion is where you take pieces
of atoms and you push them together to
make something bigger Fusion is what
happens in the sun where really small
nuclei come together and that is a huge
explosion and we've been trying to build
something like that on Earth to make
energy we haven't been able to to figure
out how to control it yet shivanu 21212
asks how will the universe end the
universe will end in the heat death of
the universe which just means that over
time the universe is expanding and all
of the light that we know about is going
to get degraded and absorbed by black
holes it just gets really cold and
really dark we won't be able to see
anything in the distance and just
nothing the heat death of the universe
is not something to worry about because
it's going to happen 40 to 50 billion
years in the future and we're only about
14 billion years from the beginning of
the universe at clown Prince Charlie
asks wait are black holes slw wormholes
actually spheres watching Interstellar
black holes are pretty much perfect
spheres if they're spinning they are a
little bit more expanded around their
equator where they're spinning than at
their poles but pretty much spheres so
in that classic image from Interstellar
you see this pretty much spherical black
hole at the center and then you see all
of this light which is the light from
the other side of the black hole getting
bent around it and that disc that you
see across the front that tells you that
the black hole is actually spinning and
every black hole that we know of is
spinning like every other star in the
universe at 52x Max asks what's so
special about special relativity well
that's relative Einstein probably
special relativity is special for a few
reasons number one it gives us a
universal speed limit which is the speed
of light nothing can go faster than the
speed of light and that's unique to
Einstein he figured this out in 1905 and
no one had really thought that there was
any kind of universal speed limit a
couple other things that are really
special about special relativity are
that it tells you if you're moving close
to the speed of light time dilates it
gets longer so if you're moving really
fast you experience time more slowly
than someone who's not moving really
fast at Cowboy vard asks can someone
explain the twin paradox to me in simple
terms you have two twins both on Earth
one of the twins decides to be an
astronaut she takes off in a spaceship
going super fast almost the speed of
light it takes her 50 years to go out to
a star and come back when the astronaut
comes back the twin that remained she's
50 years older the other twin might only
be 20 years old depending on how fast
she was going and so it's the person in
the rocket that will see time move more
slowly and will only age 20 years at AES
Force One asks the speed of light as
constant is falsehood what's the speed
of light in water slower the speed of
light as a constant is not a falsehood
we have a glass of water and I'm going
to put this pencil in there and when I
put the pencil in the pencil looks bent
the light that's coming out that you're
seeing is bent that bending comes from
the fact that as the light hits it at
some angle it sort of veers in that
direction the light's interacting with
the water it's getting absorbed and
reemitted it's seeing a little bit
longer paths as it gets scattered and
it's that that makes the light look like
it's bent those interaction actions take
a little bit of time and that's why we
say that it's effectively moving more
slowly between one interaction and the
next the speed of light is the speed of
light at Aquarius donek asks the
question is how does time dilation work
long story short time dilation is the
fact that when you're moving really
close to the speed of light time passes
more slowly it's pretty simple to write
down the time that passes for someone
who's moving at some speed is
proportional to how time is passing for
someone who's not moving at that speed
and there's this funky square root down
here and what matters is the comparison
of how fast that person's moving that's
what V is as compared to the speed of
light and in that line there and as you
go faster and faster and faster that
factor of delta T Prime gets longer and
longer and longer so time is passing
more and more slowly when you get to the
speed of light time no longer passes at
Neil Cameron 78 asks are black holes
really wormholes or are wormholes really
black holes eh eh # science we know
black holes exist we can see evidence
for them out there we've seen light
around these black holes and what it
looks like we've seen the silhouette of
a black hole wormholes are a shortcut
through SpaceTime from one place to
another the first idea of a wormhole is
something called an Einstein Rosen
Bridge it would take moving faster than
the speed of light to travel through and
we have no evidence whatsoever that
wormholes exist some physicists have
posited that if we use some of the
special characteristics of quantum field
theory that maybe we can create tiny
tiny little wormholes that we can send a
signal through from one place in
SpaceTime to another and while these
have been successful as thought
experiments and successful as computer
simulations it's not yet been seen in
the real world in a real life experiment
at Matt P1 1949 asks you think time
travel is possible under current physics
understanding no probably not at least
not from what we understand right now
there's a couple of ways to think about
how we might travel in time one way is
using a wormhole some physicists have
done this thought experiment and written
down all of the pieces you would need so
you build a wormhole that somehow
changes and tunnels through SpaceTime
back into the past you write down the
math for what that Wormhole looks like
the kind of matter that you would need
to hold that Wormhole open does doesn't
exist in our current understanding of
physics the type of matter that you
would need to hold a wormhole open is
called exotic matter things like
negative energy density which what does
that mean it means like thinking of
something with negative Mass so I don't
know if we're going to be building a
time machine anytime soon unless we can
figure out how to find and make this
exotic matter Brad Alexandre asks is
there anything infinite in the real
world or is infinity just a concept in
our minds Infinity is not just a concept
in our minds the most important Infinity
that I study is that the universe is
infinite so that's a great example of
something that's infinite we use
Infinities all the time when we're
making predictions in physics and it
turns out that the size of the universe
is infinite the amount of time the
universe will be around is also infinite
at one day wellbe okay asks quick
question does anybody know the
difference between particle physics and
quantum physics please particle physics
is a small part of quantum physics and
quantum physics is the area of physics
that really studies small stuff and the
interactions on really really small
scales but particle physics focuses on
the particles that make up atoms the
fundamental particles that make up
everything around us at Cipher 707 asks
I thought quantum physics was a fanfic
absolutely not quantum physics is how
the world works but you have to look at
a really small scale to understand
what's going on if I throw a ball up in
the air it comes down back into my hand
that's classical physics quantum physics
acts in surprising ways so instead of
having pure predictions about what's
going to happen at a Quantum level we
just get probabilities there's a 50%
chance that this thing is going to
happen a 20% chance that this other
thing is going to happen if you watch a
lot of Marvel movies I could see why
you'd think it was fanfic because it
gets used anytime you don't know how to
explain the science that you want to do
at Raven biter asks lecturer just asked
what Heisenberg contributed to physics
and loads of people answered crystal
meth that's a different Heisenberg the
Heisenberg that we know is a very famous
Quantum physicist he worked with the
German government during World War II
but he's really well known for being one
of the people who figured out all of
these rules of quantum mechanics really
early on he came up with something
called the uncertainty principle
basically if I know one aspect of a
particle like where it is I can't know
how fast it's moving very well or if I
know how fast it's moving I can't know
where it is at Tim amberie asks I just
learned about quantum entanglement and
I'm shook how can two particles be so
connected that they affect each other
even when they're light years apart is
this the secret to long-distance
relationships # Quantum love two
particles Lighty years apart can
absolutely be connected if we've set
them up in a entangled State and what
that means is we take two particles
where the measurement has something to
do with chance so if I roll this dice
whatever value I get on that face I'm
going to get the same value on the other
dice if that's how I've set up the
entangled system and these two particles
can be very very far apart from each
other and this is just how nature works
the weird part about this is the chance
that no how matter how I roll the dice
whatever it lands on the other dice will
land on the same exact value this is
just a fundamental way about how the
universe works at UTB asks what the hell
does the large hydron collider do
anyways the Large Hadron Collider is the
largest particle accelerator in the
world world it is a huge 10 km Circle in
Switzerland where we take two streams of
protons protons are a kind of hadron
hadrons are really heavy particles takes
those two streams of protons and aligns
them just right they're going almost the
speed of light not quite but almost a
speed light and smashes them into each
other the faster you can get those
protons to go the more stuff comes out
of that explosion when you smash them
together we're making new particles that
we haven't seen before they're part of
nature but they take so much energy to
make that they haven't been around since
the big bang when the universe was
really tiny and really really energetic
so not only are we learning about these
fundamental forces we're also learning
about physics right at the beginning of
our universe at physics in history asks
is string theory really a dead end no
it's not a dead end string theory is a
theory that says instead of the
fundamental pieces of the universe being
particles they're strings and these
strings can vibrate in different ways
you can have strings that are long you
can have strings that in loops and not
only does it describe all of particle
physics and quantum mechanics some
pieces of this actually predict what
quantum gravity would look like gravity
on a really small scale which is not a
theory that we have right now so those
are all the questions for today thanks
for such insightful questions thanks for
watching physics
support